it seems interesting from an outsider's
perspective to get to a point where
yeah you to come from a place of
fighting for your
peace of mind or for your comfort or to
feel okay you know
like i do stand up comedy to feel okay i
get on a stage i need something from
people
you know fighters they there's some
we're all
trying to prove something to ourselves
or to others but to come from a place of
fighting
because that's such a physical and brute
thing to then
get to a place of having some sort of
peace in your life where
um where whatever those voices are that
probably
made you so angry in the first place
that's a wild ride you guys are on
yeah and it's and it's funny too as the
sport has evolved and even even in the
very beginning of of the sport you know
the sport started
with uh you know dana white and these
guys they didn't even
start the ufc it was it was started by a
different group and then the ufc and the
fertittas
dana white bought it and turned it into
what it is today but
i'm sure there was guys who fought just
for there was no money in it either so
it wasn't like they were trying to make
a bunch of money it was really
who was the toughest who's the baddest
dude on the planet from what
uh vocation from what background you got
you got your boxer there was
a boxer wearing one boxing glove where
he could throw a jab but he could also
grapple
he had your karate guys your sumo
wrestling guys your street fighters your
whatever
back flipper some guys get in there just
do a backflip and then get their ass
kicked yeah exactly you know see
that's how it kind of started and then
and then and then it
evolved into the sport of okay we can
make a living out of this or or it's
just a really cool hobby
so you saw guys who kind of came from a
place of anger but then you see
a guy like myself i just like
hand-to-hand combat and i
and i don't i don't really like
confrontation the funny thing is i'm
very similar to you like if someone
walked in right now i wanted to fight
i'd get this weird nervous tension and
i'm like i'm not trying to fight man i'm
not here to fight but you put me inside
the cage with you and you and you put a
check on the line and it's a competition
and i can prove myself in a co in a in a
contest
of hand-to-hand combat that's when the
real competitor comes out of me because
i love the contest but i don't like the
conflict you know
um so somewhere in between there is is
where you
so some of your drive comes from the
competition aspect of it no all of it
does i think
i mean at this point i realize that
all of my all of my admirers fans or
people
who who follow me on my platforms or
want to wan
want to say man that guy is a guy that i
want my kid to be like
they don't do it because i can kick
people's ass like they don't care about
that
they do it because they say man that guy
is a
is a symbol and a manifestation of a
little guy from a little town who was
taught to do little things who had a
bunch of ups a couple downs never quit
pulled himself up by his bootstraps
dusted himself
off every time he got knocked down and
became a champion because of it now
isn't is
in the best position of his career
because of of his stick-to-itiveness and
his continued
and drive to move forward and yeah it's
really cool that he
you know it's a bonus that he likes to
bite down on his mouthpiece and get into
a brawl
inside of a a cage inside of an octagon
but really
we like him for the symbol of what he is
the
metaphor for what his his career stands
for and i think that's what
that's what i like because to me
fighting is so much
deeper than just the 15 minutes inside
the cage the 25
minutes inside the cage it's how you
live your life the honor the respect the
integrity
and the the the character that you can
build because someday i'm gonna be
retired i'm gonna look back and say man
that was a really fun ride it was
painful at times but man i
impacted a lot of people throughout it
and we had a really good time and made
some
made some some coin to be able to take
care of my family
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one